[Música]
el futuro del movimiento social en
Francia liderado por los sindicatos
ahora es incierto Emanuel macron
promulgó con rapidez este viernes la ley
de reforma pensional luego de que el
consejo constitucional aprobara las
partes esenciales del texto una decisión
que vino acompañada con la negativa a
realizar un referendo sobre la reforma
los sindicatos han prometido más
protestas y se niegan a dar por perdida
la batalla para analizar este tema
conversamos con gaela Martínez ella es
secretaria Nacional de uniones
sindicales solidaridad gaele gracias a
usted por estar en directo a América la
premura de macron para promulgar a la
ley hablemos de eso se entiende Como un
gesto de fuerza del presidente o busca
intentar cerrar cuanto antes este
capítulo que ha mermado tanto su imagen
pública
buen día a todas y todas
pues es ambos es un golpe de fuerza cada
vez con el presidente maku
No quiere escuchar a nada No quiere
escuchar a nadie hace más de tres meses
ahora que hay protestas cada semana con
millones de personas y la única cosa que
hace es promulgar la ley el día que el
consejo constitucional de chile y
sabemos que el presidente quiere cerrar
el capítulo pero el capítulo no va a
estar cerrado
para con la gente la gente no quiere
trabajar hasta
64 años y la gente va a continuar
protestar los sindicatos van a
reunirse y para decidir otras cosas
otras acciones Pues el presidente es
ambos será el capítulo y también fuerza
pero no va a pasar así claro no hay
conformidad y como indicábamos el
constitucional negó la solicitud de un
referente popular pero ya se ha
presentado una segunda solicitud por qué
se negó la primera y Qué posibilidades
hay de que la segunda salga adelante
pues para ser muy honesta no he leído
totalmente en la decisión pero yo sé que
había
unos problemas jurídicos con la primera
la primera cosa que había hecha por los
partidos políticos hay otra la decisión
será conocida el 3 de mayo
con más
pues podemos esperar y pensar que va a
pasar pero si no si no pasan no es un
problema los sindicatos y la gente va a
continuar bueno justamente para yo iba
mi siguiente pregunta porque los
sindicatos han prometido que van a
continuar las protestas Mientras que el
estado ha hablado a través del gobierno
y pues del constitucional si las
protestas no cesan Usted cree que habría
un recrudecimiento de la respuesta
estatal por ejemplo a través de más
presión policial esto teniendo en cuenta
que ya ha habido advertencias de la
policía por el uso excesivo de la fuerza
Pues es lo que podemos tener es que
ahora en Francia
Hay un problema con la represión la
represión con la asociación con los
sindicatos en las manifestaciones las
protestas todo el mundo lo ve desde el
Washington o en New York Times hasta la
ONU y en Francia y todo la gente lo ve
pero el estado y el gobierno no quiere
reconocer eso
es un gran problema porque ahora
hay gente que sufren de ir a las
protestas
un jornalista ha perdido un testículo
golpeando para la policía
un amigo del sindicato ha perdido un ojo
con lacrimógeno es un es un gran
problema en Francia y
lo que lo que mandamos Es que es que
todo esto paga y que
las límites de la de la represión sean
determinados y que todo esto para Bueno
pero usted teme por ejemplo que pueda
escaparse a los líderes de la protesta
el control de esta movilización social
porque claro hemos visto que aumenta la
violencia también aumenta la represión
policial pero la promesa por parte de
los sindicatos es mantener en lo posible
una movilización que sea pacífica
lo que hacen los sindicatos es organizar
a movilizaciones y solo es lo que
hacemos pero cuando el gobierno
no no da ninguna respuesta ningún
diálogo no sé no sé que lo que puede
pasar Es que es muy difícil cuando no
hay diálogo y no hay posibilidad de de
de de de escuchar y hacer cosas con el
gobierno bueno la imagen de macron ha
quedado muy dañada eso no es un secreto
para nadie es de lo que más se compensa
y con ella podría venir un
fortalecimiento por ejemplo para figuras
como le pene que ganaría hipotéticamente
unas elecciones usted piensa que el pene
es la más beneficiada de toda esta
situación teniendo en cuenta además que
muchos votaron previamente a macron
solamente para que ella no ganara
pues la política que está que está la
del gobierno y del presidente ahora es
pues una medida una Avenida para la
llegada de la extrema derecha es un gran
gran peligro para Francia
lo que lo que pasa efectivamente como lo
dice es que en
2022 mucha gente
ha votado por el presidente macron Para
que no gane la extrema derecha y lo que
pasa es que es muy muy muy peligroso por
el país y el presidente tiene que
escuchar eso
Bueno finalmente frente al perfil más
bajo del epénde tengo que preguntar
también por Jean Luke malanchón el líder
de las izquierdas Ha sido mucho más
activo él la Llamando a las protestas
como esperan ustedes y la izquierda
parlamentaria además recuperar el voto
siendo pues una vanguardia el movimiento
obrero que haya votado o que pueda
pensar en votar la extrema derecha
pues lo que hacen los sindicatos es que
hacemos mucho trabajo Cada día con los
obreros con los trabajadores para
explicar que es todos juntos
colectivamente que podemos luchar para
obtener
condiciones de trabajo mejor con para
mejor paga al fin de mes y para eso y
que es colectivamente que los que los
obreros tienen que organizarse y unirse
en los sindicatos y que es un gran poder
que tenemos nosotros pues mire Yo le
agradezco mucho por brindar su punto de
vista para la cadena en español es la
del Martínez secretaria Nacional de
Unión sindicales solidez gracias a usted
y que tenga un feliz día Muchas gracias
a nuestros televidentes sigan con
nosotros su ya volvemos con más de
directo a América
[Música]